عصفوراني بحجر واحد عقوبات تضغط على روسيا
وتخفيف اعباء عن المواطن الاوروبي هذا ما
يحاول الاتحاد الاوروبي للقيام به بتحديد
سقف لسعر الغاز في اوروبا ويجتمع وزراء
الطاقه للتوصل الى سعر ثابت يخفف وطات
ازمه الطاقه التي اجتاحت القاره العجوز
كذوبعه غير متوقعه اثر الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا الا ان الدول الاعضاء ليست كلها
محشوره في الزاويه الضيقه للغازي الروسي
بعضها تعتمد على الغاز الروسي بشكل اكبر
من الاخر ما يجعل وضعها اسوا من دول اخرى
فلا مقارنه بين المانيا التي تستورد 55%
من غازها من روسيا وفرنسا التي اكتفت
بسبعه في المئه فقط معتمده على مصادر اخرى
كالنرويج
ما اداب اثنتي عشره دوله من دول الاعضاء
الى المطالبه بخفض كبير لسقف الاتحاد
الاوروبي الذي يتفاوض عليه
[موسيقى]
لتبقى العقده الاكبر في الاتحاد الان ليس
الرقم بل ايجاد اليه لارضاء جميع الاعضاء
في ظل اعتماد الكتله على قاعده الاجماع
التي لا تحتمل اعتراض عضو واحد
عمليه تحديد سقف السعر تغضب موسكو
كان قد صرح ان بلاده سترفض بيع منتجاتها
من المحروقات لاي دوله تطبق السقف السعري
شتاء بارد دائما في اوروبا الا ان الحرب
الروسيه الساخنه زادت من برودته بالرغم من
ان الدول الاوروبيه مثل المانيا تؤكد ان
مخزوناتها تكفيها حتى نهايه الفصل الا
انها تشدد على ترشيد الاستهلاك اذا عمر
العربيه